histoire de christophe a commencé en
2003 à l'époque vous est conseillé
géopolitique ne l'ancien président
centrafricain puis patron d'une société
de sécurité qui lutter contre
l'islamisme radical c'était quoi votre
travail en fait en quelques mots c'était
sécuriser les industrielles en zone
hostile afin d'éviter les prises
d'otages afin d'éviter que les
industriels se fasse blessés tués et ses
coiffes était d'accord maintenir et
industriel sur site cloud d'accord alors
en 2013 après un coude et un nouveau
président arrive et privilégie la russie
les français des industriels et hommes
d'affaires sont mis dehors au profit des
russes qui colonisent le pays les
français deviennent des gens à battre
incessants c'est clair les français
deviennent des gens à abattre
l'afrique a basculé bienvenue à la
russie les français prenaient armes et
bagages surtout bagages d'ailleurs et
foutez le camp en être poussé dehors bon
voilà alors vous commenciez déjà être
une menace je commence déjà est une
menace parce que j'ai remonté un certain
nombre de services français un certain
nombre de documents qu'il s'agisse de
photos prises sur le terrain par des
hommes que j'avais encore sur zone
j'envoie des photos du matériel
militaire des hélicoptères j'en vois
aussi des comptes rendus faisant état
des programmes de formation des troupes
centrafricaine avec bien évidemment tout
ce qui va bien c'est à dire le breuvage
à la russe pour que tout le monde
comprenne que la russie est maintenant
centrafrique le m
est-ce que vous senti en danger avec
l'arrivée des russes ou bien pas tout de
suite ce n'est pas son titre en jeu au
départ je me suis très vite senti en
danger parce que parce que les russes se
sont rendus compte que des informations
sortait du pays pour venir nourrir
l'occident et partant de ce fait on a
très vite mis le doigt sur moi et ça
commençait que le début des menaces
alors comment ça s'est passé parce que
comment vous avez senti qu'à un moment
l'étau se resserrer autour de vous
ensemble l'étau se resserrer autour de
soi d'avoir canton quand on vous dit
même si tu viens plus en centrafrique il
serait bien que tu sois plus trop en
afrique ouais et puis et puis après on
vous met un mandat d'arrêt international
sur la tête parce que vous avez fait soi
disant et encore une fois c'est cette
espèce de logorrhée russe vous avez fait
soi disant fusillé 25 personnes dans une
église et puis après il ya la pression
les chantiers s'accentue et puis après
on vous dit vous avez tué trois
journalistes russes des journalistes
d'opposition que j'aurais adoré entendre
et qu'ils sont bien évidemment des
journalistes qui ont été tués par wagner
bon je crois que on a mis en face c'est
le coach parle donc économie en tuer par
wagner et puis après il ya des pressions
et puis c'est le coup de téléphone la
nuit il ya personne au bout et puis
après on vous dit que la place rouge est
pas fait pour vous et c'est quoi alors
il est vite repéré comme une menace
ils ont ils ont cherché à ce que vous
disparition
de cet accusé de plusieurs modes comme
vous nous l'avez dit mais qu'est ce qui
a fait que à un moment ça a vraiment
basculé dans un truc ou vraiment vous
avez eu très très peur prodi alors ce
qui m'a fait effectivement très très
peur c'est que quand quand vous sortez
de chez vous ou vous oubliez un peu les
choses être mis au vert or à dire est
que vous allez porter c'est pas très
poétique mais vous allez porter votre
poubelle au container et que d'un seul
coup vous avez une mercedes qui arrive à
votre hauteur les vitres décembre du
côté droit et puis et puis vous essuyez
quatre coups de feu j'ai juste eu le
temps de voir les vitres des cendres et
je me suis jetée dans le fond c'est quoi
donc voilà donc c'est ça c'est arrivé
qu'une fois c'est arrivé qu'une fois
mais bon c'est une bonne chose que
j'espère que la deuxième fois j'en ai
trop le temps de me couche à vue vous
avez d'autres d'autres alertes j'ai eu
des alertes oui j'ai eu des alertes des
passages devant chez moi avec des petits
courrier qui vont bien en disant
c'est bien que tu sors toujours à la
même heure bonds est en fait sur puis à
la même heure parce que j'ai toujours
changer mon quotidien j'ai voyagé dans
le coffre de voiture j'ai eu j'ai appelé
des gens on appelait ça l'opération
crazy dog où gisaient brrr j'appelais
des gens pour leur dire voilà opération
gizeh bros jour d'hui c'est à dire que à
telle heure on savait qu'on allait me
prendre qu'on allait m'embarquais mais
quand je ne savais pas l'avant ce
qu'elle allait être le véhicule etc pour
briser le quotidien parce que je savais
que j'étais j'étais chouf et qu'enfin
j'étais vous avez ces débrayages dans
des coffres aussi j'ai fait voyager dans
les coffres de voiture est bon j'avais
mis un peu à boire bank of parce que
c'est compliqué quand on fait de la
route mais oui je fais une orange un
coffre de voiture parce que je savais
qu'on était ont été repérés qu'ont été
accroché alors vous enchaîner les
planques vous êtes vous êtes à nantes
quand même à nantes vous avez enchaîné
les plans que vous n'avez pas de nom pas
de boîte aux lettres c'est ça c'est pas
demain pas de boîte aux lettres que je
vis que très rarement même endroit où tu
disais vous utilisez toujours des
véhicules qui ne sont pas votre nom
j'utilise des véhicules qui sont pas un
moment j'ai pas de maison qui porte mon
nom quand je voyage c'est pas toujours
moi qui voyage tout en voyageant moi
ouais c'est un peu compliqué en réalité
c'est une dit il n'est plus qui n'est
plus une vie vite car la grippe et de
toner on était d'art dans la loge on a
regardé par la fenêtre il y avait une
voiture avec quelqu'un qui était avec un
appareil photo 1 et il m'a dit tout de
suite ah bah ils sont là 1 ils sont là
ils m'ont suivi ouais non là dans la
note alors la supposition effectivement
il est venu bon je crois que c'est
peut-être ne crois que c'est un
téléspectateur de tpm pixel mort
[Rires]
une porsche
bah oui oui oui
il a regardé est extrêmement riche
vous avez été expert en sécurité vous
avez transmis des documents ma question
à l'éclair est ce que vous êtes un
espion qui travaillent pour le
gouvernement français non je ne suis pas
un espion qui travaillent pour le
gouvernement français oui je suis un
expert de la sécurité qui travaillent
dans des pays où quelquefois les
informations sont nécessaires au
gouvernement français donc vous êtes un
espion non je ne suis pas lui qu'on
appelle un honorable correspondant
absolument absolument pas c'est un
espion
c'est un honorable correspondant
bon tu lâches et geforce 8 mai
émargement pour les derniers ont payé
par l'état france voilà le temps pas
payé par l'épaule c'est un professionnel
de renseignement oui ben recruter est ce
que l'état français vous protège
aujourd'hui parce que quand on est prêt
c'est comme ça dans ma vente peuvent
entre autres une protection basséen
géométrie variable parce que vous savez
la géopolitique internationale
elle varie d'un jour sur l'autre un
cours se rapproche de vladimir à coup on
s'en éloigne c'est en fonction de ça
il se pourrait même que dans certains
cas je suis indésirable pour le service
français quand après je suis extrêmement
désirable christophe vous vous êtes
numéro cinq sur la liste de vladimir
poutine les ennemis publics oui c'est ça
mais j'ai pas pu faire mieux
tu vas passer numéro un jacob va passer
numéro de passe que vous avez
vous êtes numéro un chaman
sais pas quelle aune mieux pour vous
mais bon c'est tout est ce que ça vous
fait peur quand même vous devez la peur
au ventre alors c'est très inquiétant
parce que je vous je me situe en
cinquième position derrière des
oligarques russes qu'alors je veux dit
les oligarques ils connaissent leur boss
quoi on l'aurait fait un buzz qui sont
plus habitués moi j'avais jamais eu
affaire à vlad au maintien donc l'appel
à dons
donc aujourd'hui effectivement brochand
plaisante un peu mais très honnêtement
c'est quand même pas toujours
réconfortant sur ces faits une vie qui
se modifie donc j'hésite à l'heure c'est
une vie qui n'est plus d'une vie c'est
l'affairé un enfer pour annoncer la
cherchais je cherchais je cherchais il
m'a pas trouvé mais j'espère qu'il ne va
pas me trouver à la fois trouver une
question est-ce que vous pensez que
quand la voiture passe à côté de vous
ôter vitro se baisse et qui vous tirent
dessus c'est c'est une menace et tire à
côté ou à ce qu'ils veulent nous tuer
c'est une tentative d'intimidation pour
moi d'accord et corey camp pouvait on ne
tue pas alors pourquoi le faire ouais
pourquoi me tue pas c'est un message
qu'ont fait passer en deux mots c'est
chez moi du terme et c'est ferme ta
gueule et tout se passera bien je
connais
non mais oui avec une vie comme c'est ce
qu'on peut avoir une petite famille 510
avoir des enfants et des amis des amis
pour que vous êtes intéressés
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bon
c'est vrai mais dida pression pas manger
l'avenir je suis pas spécialement envie
de parler de ma famille parce des
raisons c'est quelquefois jours pour eux
donc voilà qu'on prend on comprend bien
c'est une question que tout le monde
s'est posé delphine la question des
défis nouy si on veut vous intimider si
le message c'est ferme ta gueule et tout
ira bien est ce que c'est parce que vous
savez des choses sur poutine qui
pourrait déstabiliser toute la russie ou
lui personnellement le faire chuter
alors faire chuter poutine il y en a
d'autres que moi qui s'y sont essayés à
il est toujours là je n'ai absolument
pas cette prétention là mais il se
pourrait que sur certaines
confrontations
je puisse avoir des éléments gênants ça
c'est certain j'ai vu des exactions sur
le terrain de wagner dans le conteneur
et beaucoup dé le groupe wagner c'est
quoi s'agit en fait de mercenaires
engagés par un groupe privé proche du
pouvoir russe et sont des personnes des
hommes extrêmement dangereux la semaine
dernière d'ailleurs france 5 j'ai voulu
révéler les dessous de cette
organisation militaire secrète russe il
aurait vu défiler dans le rang environ
dix mille agents depuis 2000 14 viols
meurtres tortures pillages rien n'arrête
ces hommes de main coupable des pires
exactions
et faire appel à un tel groupe privé
permet à moscou de défendre ses intérêts
dans le monde sans en assumer les
conséquences entraîne un voilà donc et
vous le groupe wagner c'est lui qui vous
qui vous attaquent bas c'est-à-dire
qu'ils m'aiment pas des masses quoi ils
m'aiment pas beaucoup parce que il ya
quelques temps j'avais effectivement
expliqué que le groupe wagner était
responsable du meurtre des trois
journaliste russe d'opposition en 2018
c'est ce qu'on nous
sorte qu'on vous a collé voilà et du
coup on dit mais non finalement c'est
lui qui les a fait exécuter d'accord
donc j'ai connu tout quand on vit en
disant on est la cinquième personne sur
la liste des personnes à exécuter
vladimir poutine tous les matins quand
vous vous réveillez vous dites c'est un
jour de plus
tous les matins je me dis effectivement
c'est un jour de plus
gagné sur un parcours qui pourrait être
beaucoup plus courts et tous les matins
je me dis c'est quand même une fierté
d'être sur la liste d'un mec qui est
aujourd'hui est un vrai dictateur donc
ne pas penser la même chose que lui je
trouve que c'est plus une vertu et une
fierté qu autre chose tu en entends faut
avoir un petit peu de corones et puis et
puis mélangez d'autres ac c'est beaucoup
beaucoup et oui comme ça oui mais juste
quand on connaît un peu les méthodes du
kgb de la russie si vous voulez vraiment
s'attaquer à moscou pense pas qu'il
aurait fait marrer parce que honnêtement
pour laisser on va là ils ont des
ramifications partout il puisse paraître
arrive à mettre fin à vos jours il ya
bien quelques quelques années
franchement monsieur oui pas forcément
tir gagnant bénéfice/risque calcule le
bénéfice risque
parce que c'est ils vont couper payé
peut-être plus mais on veut envoyer
redire bénéfice risque bénéfice risque
c'est martin blachier
[Rires]
j'avais tout
ça ces divisions
on
n'est pas là pour déconner bordel ben
oui oui mais si effectivement vous êtes
menacés à ce point là et qui vous ont
donné des avertissements en ferme ta
gueule en gros vous voulez pas avoir une
vie un peu normal pourquoi vous venez
sur un plateau télé pour remettre
la lumière et la lumière d'allumer hier
soir est sûre c'est la suivante il ya
trop de gens qui souffrent parce que
d'autres en fermer leur gueule alors
qu'il savait ok donc maintenant choisi
son camp si demain il m'arrive un
problème j'en serais le premier désolé
ou peut-être même plus d'ailleurs mais
en tout cas il faut dire les choses
venir si on fait partie des armes et de
coire lui en face et recule devant pas
grand chose je suis peut-être pas
grand-chose mais la pire à l'édifice que
je peux apporter je ne me gêne pas de la
porte est